Herr Dutzende Tote tausende vermisst
Warnung vor plündern ja der Hurrikan
ihren der hat ganz schön was angerichtet
Chaos in Florida viele Gebiete sind nach
dem Mega Sturm für die Retter noch immer
nicht erreichbar die Stadt Fort Myers
die Sie hier sehen die ist quasi
ausgelöscht und die Zahl der Toten die
steigt immer weiter unser Reporter
Herbert Bauer Nebel konnte mit einem
Betroffenen sprechen der deutsche Marco
Wischmeyer liebt und arbeitet in Florida
Hurricane ihn haben sein Leben und sein
Geschäft schwer getroffen
ganz kurz wie wie jetzt einige Tage nach
dem Sturm der Durchzug des Sturmes wie
ist die aktuelle Lage an welche erste
Bilanz kann man hier ziehen
Bilanz ich kann ich kann dir gar nicht
sagen wie wie fürchterlich wie nach wie
vor fürchterlich das ist es ist so
unendlich und haben immer noch kein
Strom beim kaum stabiles Mobilfunknetz
wir haben Gott sei Dank Wasser wir
können Duschen es geht Stück für Stück
vorwärts die Schäden sind
ununer menschlich du hast ungefähr 40
properties Häuser Ferienhäuser hast du
die alle inspiziert und was sind da die
schlimmsten Schäden für dich für deine
für deine dein Geschäftsbereich es ist
jedes Mal ein ein Schock wenn du die
Häuser aufmachst und dann ist Wasser
drin gewesen wir haben einige Häuser mit
Wasser in stinkt die die Feuchtigkeit
geht nicht raus das ist der entsetzlich
und persönlich hatte ich heute auch ein
ein
ist eines dieser Erlebnisse dass eben
bei sowas passiert wir haben unsere
Firma heute aufgeräumt unser Office und
es sind zwei sections sind unter Wasser
gewesen und den einen der Lager war eine
Kiste mit persönlichen die ihres von mir
von meinem Sohn als er klein war es im
Kindergarten gespielt hat und in dem
Moment
in dem Moment tut ja alles weh es ist
einfach es ist einfach ich habe das
erste Mal im Leben
verstehen sie die Leute im Aartal im
Krieg es ist ja wir fehlen die Worte
die die Bilder die aus Fort Myers Beach
seine
Commons Indien nur als apokalyptisch zu
bestreiten für jemanden der dort lebt
und dort auskennt die Gegend kennt ist
was wird mit diesen Orten passieren aber
wir haben die müssen die komplett neu
aufgebaut werden und wie siehst du die
Lage derzeit ist ist haben die Behörden
überhaupt einen Griff über
haben diese die überhaupt diese
Katastrophe im Griff wie die Menschen
das aufbauen
ich kann es Dir nicht sagen ich die
Menschen werden aufbauen wir Menschen
sind dafür gemacht aufzustehen vorwärts
zu laufen wieder ein Tag und wieder ein
Tag ich erinnere mich wir haben ich kann
die drei Tage nicht duschen wir hatten
kein warm kein Wasser wir haben
mittlerweile Wasser wir können Duschen
ich habe die erste Tasse Kaffee bekommen
sind die Kleinigkeiten aber die Menschen
die gar nicht mehr haben wo alles weg
ist das ist sowas von schlimm also
wirklich dramatisch
[Musik]
ich spreche jetzt mit unserem US-Kurs
von hinten Herbert Bauer Nebel Herbert
schöne guten Morgen wie ist die
Situation jetzt gerade in den
betroffenen Gebieten und wohin zieht der
Sturm jetzt
ja der Sturm ist weitergezogen nach New
York sorgt hier für heftigen Regen seit
fast eineinhalb Tagen inzwischen in den
sturmgebieten selbst scheint natürlich
wieder die Sonne aber die Sonne scheint
auf diese apokalyptischen Szenen die man
hier sieht besonders von diesen
küstenorden Fort Myers Beach das ist
eine
vorgeladene Halbinsel die völlig
zerstört wurde auch seine Bau Island und
andere Inseln sind praktisch ausradiert
worden von diesen Sturm die Zahlen sind
erschreckend mittlerweile ist die
todesopferzahl über 100 gestiegen es
gibt immer noch eine halbe Million
Menschen die ohne Strom auskommen müssen
es gibt nach wie vor Rettungsflüge also
Menschen die hier ausgeflogen werden
müssen mit Helikopter ungefähr 1600
solche Rettungen hat es bereits gegeben
dazu fehlt es an allen von
Handyverbindungen bis zum nötigsten
Wasser Nahrungsmittel all das wird hier
hin es geschafft aber gleichzeitig
beginnen hier viele Menschen mit den
Aufräumungsarbeiten bereits packen zu
versuchen auch in ihren Häusern noch zu
retten was zu retten ist besonders
natürlich auch diese privaten
Gegenstände die halt so viel bedeuten
für viele Menschen wie man vorher gehört
hat all das passiert jetzt es gibt viel
Hilfe seitens des Staates natürlich aber
auch Kritik kommt auf über die Tatsache
dass hier offensichtlich zu spät gewarnt
wurde das ist zu spät einen
Evakuierungsbefehl gegeben hat für diese
gefährdeten Gebiete und einige Menschen
sagten an es ist zu spät zum flüchten
sind geblieben und dann eben in diese
Situation geraten allerdings es gibt
auch sehr viele die Evakuierung
verweigert haben die gesagt ich bleibe
zu Hause ich kenne Hurricanes ich lebe
in Florida und die haben natürlich auch
einen schrecklichen Fehler gemacht ganz
makaber ist die Tatsache dass bei den
Sucharbeiten die immer noch vor sich
gehen auch sehr viele Taucher jetzt im
Einsatz sind die schauen ob es auch
unter Wasser noch Tote gibt bleichen
gibt die geborgen werden müssen Herbert
wie viele Menschen werden in der Zeit
noch vermisst und wie schätzt du das ein
das Ausmaß der zerstörungs ist so riesig
wie lange glaubst du wird überhaupt der
Wiederaufbau dauern
Wiederaufbau wird dauern Monate Jahre
die Zahl der Vermissten ist schwer
einzuschätzen weil es natürlich kein
Register gegeben hat wer sich wo
aufgehalten hat aber klar ist es war ein
k.o.-schlag der Mutter Natur und es wird
ein langer langer Weg zurück werden für
diese Katastrophengebiete
Herbert Bauer Nebel uns zugeschaltet aus
New York vielen herzlichen dank dir für
deine Informationen
[Musik]